[Music]
we don't actually know the extent to
which gender is socially constructed
because you can't do an experiment where
you remove culture and see what happens
so we don't know to what extent what we
see as gendered patterns are the result
of sex biological sex males and females
we know that gender differs according to
culture but we also know that there are
patterns that appear to be fairly
universal in terms of gender norms and
the ones that are more universal are
more likely to probably have a sex basis
to in an evolved sex basis that is to
say a biological basis for males and
females
so for example who which gender serves a
very important meal may be different by
different cultures so in some cultures a
man will serve a very important male
versus a woman so for example think
about in the United States that
historically speaking the Father carves
the turkey on Thanksgiving but in
general women prepare food historically
speaking so what we know is that these
kinds of things can differ by culture
but that there are some universals and
one of the universals we find for
example is in childhood play that we
find that children who are girls tend to
do more social play they tend to do more
social role play children who are boys
tend to do more competitive play they
tend to do more play that mimics
aggression or that mimics sport and
mimics sometimes building and so there
are these kinds of patterns but that
doesn't mean everybody fits them and
it's really interesting actually too if
you look across culturally scientists
find evidence that this may have it's
not just gender that there's a sexuality
component to it too so boys who are
going to grow up and be gay and we know
who they are because of retrospectively
they grow up to be gay they're what's
called Andra philic that is to say
they're attracted to males and the
majority of females are also attracted
to males so most females are under
philic and a small percentage of boys
are Andrew will grow up to be under
philic we know that historically
speaking cross-culturally they
to be more feminine in terms of their
interests they're more interested in
social roleplay for example they're more
interested in helping their mothers
they're more interested in associating
with girls as young children and more
inches in dressing as girls for example
that doesn't mean that they're girls but
it does suggest to us that sexuality and
gender have inter played components in
them that gender isn't just about social
role that it has something to do with
sexuality and that there's a reason
females end up with these kinds of
patterns and males end up with these
kinds of patterns and when you have a
male who's attracted to males he ends up
with a little bit more of the female
pattern and in some circumstances if you
have a girl and she's attracted to girls
she'll end up with a little bit more of
the male pattern in childhood so gender
and sexual orientations seem to have
sort of some connection to each other
but it's not a perfect connection in
terms of absolute correlation and so we
can't say that we can easily predict
what would be somebody's gender role or
sexual orientation simply by looking at
some of the components evolution would
naturally favour heterosexuality because
that's how you get babies and so if
we're thinking about genes trying to
produce genes it would make no sense to
have genes that would lead to people who
don't reproduce because those genes
would not be reproduced that said we
know cross culturally gay people exist
so we know that that's a natural
variation in the population and so then
scientists asked the really interesting
question why is that there why does that
not disappear over time because at least
in theory that should lead to lower
reproductive fitness which means it
should lead to fewer babies and so it
should it should fade out evolutionarily
speaking one possibility is that it's a
side effect that human variation is good
for the species and so evolution is
responding to the situation not by
reducing necessarily everything that
doesn't work but saying let's keep
throwing up variation and some of it
will work in some environments and some
of it will work in other environments
being a varied species makes the species
more resilient so it may be the case
that being gay if you're born that way
is just a variation on a theme and it
will show up there we now and then just
because variations show up but some
scientists find some evidence that there
may actually be advantages to a family
of
having a certain percentage of the
children be gay and this has work done
for example by Paul Basie at the
University of Lethbridge and he's been
looking at the population in Samoa as
well as other places but Samoa has a
cultural system that actually recognizes
that a certain percentage of the boys
are going to grow up to be
Andrew feel like they're going to be
interested in men sexually and they
actually of a whole cultural system for
it they have a third gender category
called the 15a and when a boy it becomes
evident is that kind of boy the child is
raised as a girl and becomes a woman
culturally speaking but doesn't change
her body at all but partners with men so
in our culture that would be called
transgenderism but in this culture it's
a third gender category that absorbs
what in our culture might just turn out
to be gay men and what Paul has found is
that when he looks at the families that
have Afeni within them they the 15-a are
not using up a lot of resources because
they're not themselves having children
these are big family cultures but they
do take their own earnings and they
directed at their nieces and nephews and
that means you have more adults
producing more resources for a smaller
number of children so biologically there
may be an advantage for families to have
a certain number of gay children because
those people will not reproduce but they
will take care of the nieces and nephews
and so overall the population the
genetics of the family will be continued
on because that family has a genetic
advantage and you know when you think
about it we have this sort of stereotype
of the gay uncle who takes care of the
nieces and nephews in terms of providing
for them and providing extra resources
and they're not spending it on their own
kids they're spending it on their
sisters and brothers children that might
be a possible evolutionary explanation
for why it is that we see homosexuality
persist in the human system it's also
the case we know from work done by Rae
Blanchard in Canada that a certain
number of men who will grow up to be gay
get that way not through genetics per se
but they get that way in the womb so
it's in born but not genetic and what
happens is apparently well we know we
know statistically from huge studies now
if a mother has lots of
agencies of males every successive male
will be a little bit more likely to be
gay so the farther down you go in that
sibling chain the more likely it is that
the later born males will be gay so this
has been studied in many populations in
the world large numbers and it's
rigorous we know that this is true so
why would that be well it looks like
it's a kind of side effect the mother's
immune system appears to be reacting to
male hormones and maybe dampening them
down a little bit and this results in
something called the fraternal birth
order effect which is that later born
males are more likely to be gay it's a
surprising finding because it suggests
to us that some men are absolutely born
gay but not because of genetics they're
born gay because of the birth order in
terms of some sort of effect having on a
woman woman's system which is reacting
to her children's system and it only
occurs in males doesn't occur in females
and that's part of the reason why the
theory is it's an immune response
because it doesn't occur with females it
only occurs with males born out of the
same womb so that's something I've
colloquially called wound gay but it's
called the paternal birth order effect
and I think the evidence is very strong
that a certain percentage of gay people
are born that way we do not have good
evidence that straight people are born
that way we don't bother to look for
that evidence straight straight people
have been less interesting to scientists
than gay people in terms of where they
come from and that's because there's a
heterosexist assumption that straight
people require no explanation and gay
people require explanation I mean is in
terms of evolution gay people do require
an explanation logically speaking we
should say well that that's not a very
successful strategy as it's called in
science it doesn't lead to a higher
reproductive fitness meaning it doesn't
lead to more babies so logically you
would want to explain gay people but
it's also a political issue that
basically straight people have required
no explanation and gay people have
required explanation and some of the
explanations historically have been
rather unpleasant like blaming mothers
who are frigid for being or overly
clingy in the case of being gay overly
clingy mothers make gay boys what we
know from cross-cultural studies is that
gay boys are more interested in being
with their mothers and straight boys and
it's not that the mothers are more
clingy it's that the boys are more
tolerant of time with their mothers
so we've studied much more about gay
people than we have studied about
straight people and straight people
remain largely a mystery as to how they
operate what makes them straight we
don't really know we also don't know why
gay people are attracted to each other
anymore than we know why straight people
are attracted to each other we have
hints about smells and about genetic
interactions and about facial symmetry
but we really know very little about why
straight people are straight and why gay
people are gay
[Music]
you